el salvador es un país pequeño de hecho
es el más pequeño de américa central
esto sí con 6 millones y medio de
habitantes su población es mayor que la
de panamá costa rica belice o nicaragua
y eso a pesar de que la emigración ha
sido y aún es un fenómeno muy
generalizado según las diferentes
estimaciones ojo entre 3 y 4 millones de
salvadoreños viven en el extranjero
sobre todo en eeuu lo digo así de bajito
para que no me diga trump y no os
penséis que esta moda ha pasado cada año
son miles más los que hacen las maletas
y se lanzan a la aventura de buscar
fortuna en otro lugar vamos que a este
paso van a hacer más los salvadoreños
que ven fuera que los que vienen dentro
pero es posible que os estáis
preguntando hay alguna razón para
semejante éxodo bien es verdad que el
salvador es un país muy pobre pero en
esta ocasión no se trata sólo de eso
ahora veremos qué es lo que realmente
está detrás de esta gran huída pero
antes de nada un apunte este país
tropical donde podemos encontrar playas
impresionantes recetas naturales como
esta o increíbles reliquias mayas está
en 2017 de celebración y es que en este
año se cumple el 25 aniversario de los
acuerdos de paz que pusieron fin a una
brutal guerra civil que duró más de 12
años y causó más de 70.000 muertos
i
el conflicto enfrentó a las fuerzas
armadas con el llamado frente farabundo
martí para la liberación nacional un
grupo guerrillero paramilitar de
izquierdas que era apoyado por el
régimen cubano por cierto tras los
acuerdos de paz este grupo guerrillero
se convirtió en partido político y hoy
ostenta ni más ni menos que la propia
presidencia de la república menudo
cambio verdad ejerce de la presidencia
como redes
eficiencia y transparencia el caso es
que este 25 aniversario tendría que ser
un gran motivo de alegría pero la verdad
es que dada la situación del país no
parece que existan muchos motivos para
la celebración
de la violencia
el pasado 11 de enero de 2017 un
miércoles como cualquier otro sucedió
algo tan especial que lo que pasó es que
precisamente no ocurrió nada si no me
vuelto loco ese día terminó con un
balance de 0 víctimas mortales en el
salvador y si esto es noticia en los
últimos años
amigos de visual política el salvador se
ha convertido en uno de los países más
peligrosos del mundo para que os hagáis
una idea en 2015 se registraron en este
país 6 mil 670 asesinatos
[Música]
es decir 105 por cada 100.000 habitantes
la mayor tasa de muertos de un país no
en guerra en todo el mundo la cifra da
verdadero terror en términos relativos
es algo así como si en españa se
cometiesen al año casi 50.000 asesinatos
para que nos hagamos una idea en
realidad se producen poco más de 300 así
que ya os podéis imaginar la diferencia
en 2016 el dato ha sido algo inferior
pero aún así han sido aproximadamente
4.000 los asesinatos que se han
registrado es una locura hay guerras con
menos víctimas y claro a estas muertes
tenemos que añadir los secuestros las
extorsiones los robos en fin un panorama
como se suele decir coloquialmente
bastante negro desde luego todo esto no
anima a pasar por allí más vacaciones al
menos que te llame jessica fletcher y
estáis escribiendo un nuevo libro
[Música]
y sicav leche nuestro polizón se
escondió en el interior del maletero
cuando el avión despegó en fin por todo
ello no podemos extrañarnos que según
las últimas encuestas casi la mitad de
la población afirme que le gustaría
dejar el país
y es que como podéis imaginar toda esta
violencia tiene consecuencias no sólo en
cuanto al miedo sino también sobre el
propio nivel de vida de la gente según
un estudio del banco central de reserva
de el salvador la violencia cuesta cerca
de cuatro mil millones de dólares cada
año y sabéis que estoy seguro de que esa
cifra se queda muy corta porque al fin y
al cabo quién va a invertir su dinero en
un país donde te pueden matar a las
primeras de cambio no me creéis el
salvador es el país con menor inversión
extranjera de toda centroamérica
el desastre es tal que en este país es
más peligroso ser conductor de autobús
que policía en los últimos cinco años
las pandillas han matado a casi 700
conductores
en la región
es verdad es algo conocido casi una
verdad universal latinoamérica tiene un
problema muy serio con la violencia y el
crimen fijaros según un informe de la
consultora michael crow latinoamérica es
la región del mundo con mayor riesgo de
sufrir crímenes violentos y seis de los
diez países más peligrosos se encuentran
aquí
de hecho uno de cada tres homicidios y
cada año se producen en el mundo ocurre
en latinoamérica pues aun con todo el
llamado triángulo norte de américa
central que está compuesto por el
salvador honduras y guatemala se lleva
la palma y es con mucho la zona más
peligrosa del continente bueno es más es
que esta zona es la región no en guerra
más peligrosa de todo el mundo aquí en
estos tres países han sido asesinadas
casi 200.000 personas desde 2004
sólo de pensarlo amigos se me ponen los
pelos de punta tiene que ser horrible la
sensación de no poder andar
tranquilamente por la calle no poder
enseñarle siquiera un reloj o una cadena
y pensar que en cualquier momento les
puede pasar algo a tus familiares oa tus
amigos en fin no poder montar un negocio
sin tener que pagar la habitual mordida
a los criminales de turno
en fin terrible pero la pregunta es a
qué se debe tanta violencia
[Música]
narcotráfico y maras aunque parezca
mentira estos tres países de
centroamérica no han sido siempre en
lugares peligrosos de hecho se puede
decir que hasta hace un par de décadas
estos países eran relativamente
pacíficos al menos en lo que se refiere
al día a día de la gente sin embargo
todo esto comenzó a cambiar a finales de
los 80 y los 90 por dos motivos
básicamente el narcotráfico y las maras
[Música]
primero el narcotráfico es un problema
muy serio en toda la región cada año 22
millones de estadounidenses consumen
drogas y la inmensa mayor parte de ellas
proceden de sudamérica los cárteles
literalmente se forran con este negocio
[Música]
para todos
estoy hablando
este no es desde luego un fenómeno nuevo
pero sí es una actividad que evoluciona
continuamente para saltarse la legalidad
la persecución a los archiconocidos
cárteles colombianos condujo a que la
tradicional ruta colombia islas del
caribe florida diese paso a otra que
atraviesa américa central y aquí está el
primer gran problema en buena medida
esta zona se ha convertido en una
especie de santuario para los ahora
poderosos carteles mexicanos desde
américa central organizan el negocio
esconden la mercancía y en su caso se
refugian para escapar de la justicia
para que os hagáis una idea de lo que
esto implica los expertos calculan que
el 80% de la droga que se consume en
estados unidos pasa por honduras así que
yo os podéis imaginar de dónde procede
en parte tanta violencia por otro lado
tenemos a las maras para los que nos
conozcáis son grupos pandilleros que se
dedican a todo tipo de actividades
criminales como el robo el asesinato o
la extorsión generalmente están
compuestas por gente joven y su
organización es relativamente horizontal
es decir no se construye en tanto sobre
una jerarquía piramidal sino sobre la
existencia de muchos comandos conocidos
como clicas que funcionan con relativa
independencia se calcula atentos que tan
solo en los tres países que hemos
comentado las maras cuentan con entre
70.000 y 100.000 miembros las más
famosas son las maras salvatrucha y
barrio 18 que por cierto suelen errar
entre sí por el control de diferentes
territorios
y lucha contra la violencia el escenario
es complejo han intentado muchas
estrategias y hasta ahora todas han
fracasado sin embargo en los últimos
tiempos se están poniendo en marcha dos
iniciativas que persiguen cambiar la
realidad de estos países y lograr
seguridad para la gente la primera de
ellas es la conocida como la fuerza de
tarea trinacional un aparato de
seguridad compuesto por policías
militares expertos en inteligencia y
unidades especiales de los tres países a
los que nos hemos referido antes este
grupo nace con la misión de combatir a
las pandillas al narcotráfico y al
crimen organizado con independencia de
las fronteras el grupo contará además
con el apoyo el entrenamiento y la
financiación de eeuu
como dije juan orlando hernández el
presidente de honduras la idea es clara
les vamos a dar su propia medicina por
otro lado y vinculada a la primera está
el proyecto conocido como alianza de la
prosperidad que ha sido impulsado por la
administración obama y que espera lograr
mejoras en las condiciones de vida y la
competitividad de estos países
su meta primordial es lograr crear
empleos e infraestructuras esenciales
que permitan revertir la terrible
situación actual para empezar
washington ya comprometido 750 millones
de dólares para apoyar estas iniciativas
la pregunta es hay esperanza siempre
tiene que haber la de momento la mara
salvatrucha del salvador ya ha
comunicado que estaría dispuesta a
negociar incluso su desmantelamiento el
tiempo dirá qué resultados se consiguen
por cierto si nos estás viendo desde el
salvador sabemos que probablemente éste
no sea el tipo de vídeo que esperabas
ver sobre tu país pero creemos que no
podíamos haber dejado de denunciar esta
atrocidad en nuestro primer vídeo sobre
la zona en fin y vosotros qué pensáis
conseguirán estos países librarse de los
criminales
éxito el plan liderado por washington
esperamos vuestras respuestas y tener
presente que aunque no siempre podamos
contestar a todos los mensajes y
comentarios que nos enviáis sí que
procuramos leerlos todos por cierto si
queréis saber cuál es la última
dictadura de europa
gemma nos lo cuenta en este vídeo y si
aún no lo habéis hecho todavía no
olvidéis que podéis suscribiros a
nuestro nuevo canal en inglés un saludo
y hasta la próxima
es cuestión de lógica con que estés a
gusto tanto sobre las pruebas de nitrato
escribo novelas de misterio y me dedico
investigando antes físico echándole un
vistazo a los hechos
[Música]